fue un escenario de incertidumbre para
europa el mantenimiento del gasoducto
más importante del viejo continente que
durará por lo menos 10 días ha puesto a
europa a buscar alternativas energéticas
ante un posible corte definitivo de las
entregas por parte de rusia occidente ha
señalado a moscú de usar el corte de gas
como respuesta a las sanciones que se le
han impuesto en castigo a su invasión a
ucrania el kremlin se ha desmarcado de
esas acusaciones
rechazamos totalmente cualquier
declaración de que la parte rusa está
utilizando el petróleo y el gas para
ejercer presión política hay ciertos
trabajos de mantenimiento en los
gasoductos estos trabajos se realizan
todos los años nadie ha inventado
ninguna reparación nueva
rusia ha señalado a canadá de ser el
principal culpable de que el gasoducto
opere sólo a un 40 por ciento de su
capacidad luego de que el país
norteamericano no entregara unas
turbinas necesarias para el
mantenimiento del nord stream y mientras
ucrania se opone a que canadá colabore
en el mantenimiento del gasoducto moscú
ha puesto la entrega como condición
necesaria para aumentar el suministro a
europa
lo que ocurra una vez que se haya
realizado el mantenimiento está por
verse nadie puede predecirlo se trata de
un mantenimiento que termina en 10 días
o antes o después por desgracia tenemos
que esperar a ver qué pasa
afortunadamente alemania sigue
recibiendo gas de noruega a través de
las terminales de gas natural licuado en
bélgica y países bajos dimensión
italia es uno de los primeros
damnificados del cierre temporal en
donde ya se habla de un racionamiento de
las empresas energéticas y un control
del consumo de la calefacción y
alumbrado público
alemania el país europeo que más depende
del gas ruso ya había empezado a tomar
medidas y según su ministro de economía
el abastecimiento de energía está
completamente garantizado